hi guys and welcome to this week's
episode as you know we're partnered with
cutie which is a social media company
that tries to create a space for
interesting insightful conversations
like the ones that we have here so head
over to the link in the Pin comment and
in the description to get your chance to
say what you think and we're doing
things a little bit differently this
week
now we're interviewing Lou Perez who is
a comedian which is going to be a great
interview and you're going to love it
however we are going to be talking about
the coronavirus on this week's cutie
because the world is [ __ ] ending and
why not yeah let's have a chat about how
we're all about to die so head over to
the link in the pinned comment and we'll
see you there the top 5 answers will get
pinned and discussed in next week's
stream so enjoy the show
enjoyed the episode with the brilliant
loop errors of weed the Internet Doug
Allen is about to bring it again dating
is hard he's not holding back especially
if you're dating a straight white man
because this time he's taking on a
sacred cow you go on two dates with a
straight white man and they think well I
guess I own you now the one thing you
are not allowed to make fun of ladies
you ever trying to get into bed with a
straight white man uh-huh it's weird
you can't fit because that motherfuckas
privilege is taking up half the bed
Doug Allen presents straight white men
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and kisses
and this is a show for you if you're
bored with people arguing on the
internet over subjects they know nothing
about a trigonometry we don't pretend to
be the experts we ask the experts are
fantastic guests this week is the
producer and head writer and we the
internet Lou Perez welcome to
trigonometry thanks for having me guys
it's great to have you I've been
watching your videos and really enjoying
them but for anyone who doesn't know
what you do just tell us a little bit
about it sure we the internet TV is a
comedy news channel we mostly do
political satire we take on politics and
culture and that sort of thing and we're
available on YouTube Facebook all online
social media platforms and you've got an
interesting angle like some other
showing the guys some of your stuff is
really funny like you were talking there
was this bit about an edgy comedian Doug
Doug Allen yeah yeah for those of you
you know across the pond who aren't
familiar with the edgiest comedian who
dares to make fun of people like Donald
Trump and all that that's that's Doug
Allen and that came out of I there's a
writer named Lucas Bellino so he and I
both developed Doug Allen and we put on
these these fake comedy trailers for
Doug Allen's stand-up specials where
he's saying outrageous edgy stuff that
no one is brave enough to say and and
what's amazing is the amount of people
who watch it and think that it's real
like it's actually it's gotten to the
point where they're like oh you see that
on late-night television all the time
and like and then like going into the
comments and like trying to actually
deal with these people
so occasionally you'll have someone
you'll call them I'll be like hey you
know he's not a real character and then
the back oh my god I can't believe I
fell for it then other people just you
know sort of dig in they're like you
guys suck you know well our friend who
wrote who created the character - tani
McGrath
Angie Doyle he has a very same thing
with with titania like he posts the most
outrageous things like you know there's
nothing Y about me except my skin color
or something like that and he got loads
of people taking it
face-value it says quite a lot I think
about where we are culturally but in
terms of with the internet what's the
kind of angle that you guys are coming
at things from yeah so we we describe
ourselves as equal opportunity offenders
and you know when you're making fun of
politics you know we're dealing with a
lot of competition right so you have
professionals in late-night television
you have comedy shows and all that and
everybody is going after the same
material so it's sort of our job to see
what angle isn't being taken you know to
try to be funny and original and have
original takes on it so that's what
we're at because a lot of from what I
see comedy and you know particularly
like you know the late night shows or
Tonight Show they tend to have a liberal
bent to them but I don't see a lot of
conservative comedy coming from the US
would you describe yourself as being a
conservative outlets well it's it's
tough now to even to know what
conservative means because I have so
many friends of mine who were you know
liberals Democrats and they tell me you
know like they like glue I believe the
same exact things I believed five years
ago but for some reason if I talk about
them I'm worried that I'm going to get
in trouble so it's sort of like people
are being and kind of pushed into the
conservative you know the conservative
bent or whatever that or the being
labeled ISKCON every label those
conservatives without even considering
themselves conservatives there's a lot
of work that I've done in the past like
I got my first job out of out of college
I wrote erotic fiction for a living
I wrote dirty stories for a living like
that was my first job that's not really
a job that I would say that conservative
would really take you know writing so I
can't believe like there's no reason for
me to bring that up there's a case the
comedy thing doesn't work don't want
everybody to know that I could go that
route again
yeah and write dirty stories that's the
only reason you've come and trigonometry
you want you want you wanted some jobs
doing that exactly my erotic fiction
career needs to be picked up yeah he's
funny that you say that because we have
a kind of more libertarian comedian in
this country Simon Evan
who used to write pornography for this
yeah yeah and so maybe that's what you
kind of said you're a libertarian which
no one in the UK knows what it means but
it means you're problematic very very
problematic well even in the United
States you know libertarians you know
people don't necessarily know what that
it so you'll I think sometimes
libertarians will be labeled Republicans
who smoke weed which is a you know like
a very like over simple simplified way
of putting it for me as a as a small L
libertarian I'm not a part of a
libertarian party my whole thing comes
down to this idea of a voluntary
exchange between between people that I
don't want any initiation of force I
don't want people forcing others to do
their do their bidding and I sort of
take that from the personal you know the
personal plays between this is all
voluntary and then sort of expand that
to you know groups and etc etc and a lot
of times that includes for the most part
things like you know smaller government
and rights as far as what you can and
cannot put in your body the idea is if
you're not hurting anybody else you
should be able to put whatever you like
in your body that sort of thing and what
challenges do you face when it comes to
rights in political comedy because -
right
for instance a Trump joke is
phenomenally difficult because there's
so many people like you said going after
the same terrain yeah I think it I think
it's but like anything you know being
original is the is a tough part point
and then also being able to do a joke
and not lose the audience right from the
get-go
so sometimes there'll be videos that
that we put out and people like oh this
is just right-wing propaganda and it's
like well I didn't really consider
right-wing propaganda I thought it was
me taking an idea and developing it and
and trying to do something with it and
then other times though I you know will
be called you know you Lib tardes which
is do you guys have a Lib tardes here
and I'm a lipped are you
no I actually I want to take that back
for libertarian yeah like I wanted a
live [ __ ] to be the libertarian thing
it's not working out well in in the US
but it's funny it's like depending on
which if you if you have a if you have a
weird nuanced view of the world I think
people were so used to you know
everybody's sort of being in a box where
if you believe this you must believe
this this and this therefore I can see
one thing that you did over here and
make all these sweeping assumptions
about where you fall on these other
political issues okay usually it's me
interrupting you so yeah I'll be the
I'll be the gentleman okay it's unusual
to hear Russian use a word that
gentleman but anyway the question I was
going to ask you is so how do you
approach your comedy in the sense that
normally when you're a political
comedian you have a political agenda so
you're a left-wing comedian that's your
left wing agenda or whatever else do you
have a political agenda or is it just
finding the funny I think it's just for
me it's it's finding the funny a lot of
stuff that I do I also do stand-up as
well so when I'm onstage a lot of things
are you know self-deprecating humor I
guess if you want to call it that or
talking about things in my own life and
I feel like a lot of times when it comes
to political humor there's this risk of
going full-blown activism and I think
when you go full-blown activism people
can sniff it out and then it's like well
now I'm I'm no longer seeing an act or
no longer hearing jokes I'm I'm hearing
you know an activist speak and that's
something that I'm trying that you know
I think everybody should be really
conscious of when they're when they're
doing that it's like you said though
it's becoming quite difficult because I
do political comedy as well and the
problem is that whenever I mean making
fun of a politician or a political
movement or a party or whatever it's now
automatically interpreted as criticism
and it used to be I feel that you could
make fun of both sides and if you kind
of went through your 10 or 15 20
whatever minutes hour or an hour show
and you kind of punched at everybody
that was fine but now people would just
go you made this one joke about Trump or
one
about Hillary or one joke about whoever
and that's you now and now we've
disagreed with you and now you know
Jenna I'm saying yeah yeah and and I
think a lot of times political comedy is
supposed to be this idea of holding up a
mirror to society and I and I think one
thing we have to be careful of is to
remember to actually turn that mirror
around and look at ourselves and be like
ooh you know I don't have all the
answers and I don't necessarily know I
don't know what's going on with with
with everything we had an incident very
recently actually in this country where
a comedian who hosts the only real
equivalent we have to what you're late
shows who was doing a show to a group of
people who were kind of the the
blue-collar type of audience at a
charity gig and he was doing he was very
anti brexit material which I guess would
be a bit like and doing anti Trump
material you know in the Rust Belt
somewhere something about that and he
got pelted with bread and booed off
stage and it was really the first time
that we've I think it's the first time
that that's really happened I mean a
couple of other people have been talking
about it so it seems like it's becoming
very polarized in that way and I think
like you said comedians maybe need to
take a bit more responsibility as well
for just being activists on stage rather
than just doing jokes right well also I
think it weren't really weird times
where like in the United States if if
you are a trump supporter people are
support him so much where it's become
almost a you know sort of a personality
trait in a way where they don't trust
the mainstream media and you know
sometimes there's good reason you know
to be to be skeptical of you know
stories that that you're seeing in the
media but they they don't trust the
media so much that they start to take
any form of criticism as a personal
attack and I've noticed that you know
with them with with my own stuff where
fans who have been following me and
really enjoy when I make fun of social
justice warriors or when I make fun of
an Tifa the second I
I you know make a joke about Trump it's
like oh I'm done with you guys it's over
that's like really this is what it like
this one punchline that's all it took
for you to you know think that that you
know I'm I'm garbage now no longer
worthy of having you around and so it's
a little scary because I I fear that
that the divisive Ness is just gonna
it's just gonna keep separate us and
separating us until we you know can't
tell you know what is a joke and what
you know what is true what you know what
what's fact with fiction and all that
and we're not talking and I think that's
a really big problem and do you think
audiences have become more sensitive
since you've been know so for instance
so when did you start stand-up comedy I
started comedy think I think maybe like
17 years ago I started in college and I
started with improv and sketch comedy
yeah and then I've been doing stand-up I
think for probably like 10 years and in
that time
so you've you're mainly new york-based
yeah you must have you must have seen
audiences change do you think we've
become more sensitive as it as a society
and as an audience in a comedy club or
do you think things have remained kind
of similar you know I'm not I'm not sure
I wonder it might be that nowadays you
have an outlet to talk about your
sensitivity you know whether it's you
know going on social media and talking
about a comedian that you saw I'm not
sure I think I think it only seems like
it used to be if if you were offended by
a joke or you know you found something
that was you know like no that's just
wrong you would say mmm I'm not into
that and then move on whereas now it's
um it's almost like it's incumbent upon
you to talk about how offended you are
and how wrong that that joke was I'm not
sure yeah you have to call it out call
it out yeah yeah yeah well now you can
that's sort of your way of being part of
the fight in a way yes it's not
necessarily that more people are
becoming offended it's more that when
people are they they amplify that to a
great degree
I mean look in London I I know I speak
to a lot of people in France as hosts a
lot of different shows at some of the
better clubs in in London I speak to
other
best clubs you talk to people who host
shows or emcee shows like that and the
level of complaints about a comedian
being whatever offensive in some way has
never been higher even as as comedian
we're becoming increasingly careful
about the kind of stuff that we we do so
certainly in this country it has been
happening I don't know whether it's it's
the case in New York or elsewhere in
these states yeah I haven't luckily I
haven't experienced that that much I
have a friend of mine who who owns a
club and it be interested a because well
yeah I guess it's it's one of those
things where also how do you quantify it
to you know if you have you know two
hundred people packed into a room and
five of them leave a terrible review are
we to assume that the other 195 either
had a good time
or you know they had an okay time or
some of them had a bad time but they
were just they were so offended and so
traumatized that they're not even able
to talk about it I don't know don't you
think it's also part of comedies remit
to offend to push the boundaries I
remember the first time I saw Chris Rock
is when he did the black they're all
black people rotate sure and do you want
to do that that'll be one way to end the
channel anyway um and I was the oh there
was about eight people in the room I was
in University and I was the only white
guy in the room and we were watching it
and I was watching the reaction from
everybody else and I was like am I
allowed to offers it but black people
offering it is a white person about it
isn't that the purpose of comedy to test
the boundaries racism yeah you know of
what is and isn't acceptable and
and are we making things too safe at the
moment well I think you know comedy is a
way to go after sacred cows so whatever
the sacred cow is it's sort of you know
might be the duty of a comedian you know
you could you can volunteer for the job
to take on whatever that sacred cow is
and I remember talking to people about
that that Chris Rock bit and apparently
it took him a really long time to get it
to the point where it wasn't offensive
to also black audiences yeah apparently
he was working on that material a lot
and it wasn't it wasn't working in in
black rooms so I think I think there I
think that there's something there too
you know being willing to fail as well I
mean I mean I'm sure if you guys look at
your notebooks and just how many jokes
are just they were great in your head or
or even like oh man this is gonna piss
some people off or or and then you go
and you do it live and you're like aw
what a waste of my life no it's just the
worst but also I think it comes down to
you know how are you gonna choose on you
know what you know what art to you know
to spend your time looking at or
listening or listening to I want it to
be something that I haven't heard before
something that the best thing about
about laughter is when it's
uncontrollable so you know even you know
some of the most horrendous jokes if it
got you laughing it's like it did
something right yeah yeah well the thing
with the Chris Rock bit is really
interesting what you say there about him
having to work on it for a long time
this is where I feel the issue maybe is
that if you need to work on a routine er
which we all do to try and make it find
that place between funny and offensive
where it's it's it's just right
you're gonna have to go - oh this is
just offensive at some point right and
you have to have the space to do that if
you if you're not if you're not if you
don't have that opportunity then you
know there's going to be routines that
are never going to be born
because they're gonna be just killed at
birth because you've got oh no I it's
too offensive I can't try this out and
you can't get it to to its logical
conclusion yeah it's it the challenge is
there to because it's not like all
subjects are equal you know obviously
it's it's a lot it's much easier to talk
about you know a relationship like a a
bad date than it is to talk about a bad
day that leads to an abortion like well
then that's it right no it's at
opportune so there's a challenge there
well how do you make these really
sensitive controversial subjects
palatable and funny and you know there
are people who can do it and others who
can't and others who are like I don't
even want to touch that
hmm I find that the whole you know
Chapelle special thing very very
interesting as in you know the
mainstream media's reaction to it as
opposed to you know the average punter
audience member who loved it and I mean
the thing that summed it up the best was
a Rotten Tomatoes review from the
critics and then the audience rating
right yeah and in that word there was
this but in the sticks and stones yeah
right
and I hadn't I I wasn't looking forward
to seeing this special or anything like
that I had no interest in seeing it I
it's on Netflix and Netflix is just full
of there's so many specials and I'm like
I can't get to all them the only reason
why I watched it was because of the
controversy you know everybody talking
about you know and then finally I
watched I watched with with my wife in
like every five minutes I'm cracking up
and like balled over and laughter and
it's like Yankee that's what that's what
it's supposed to do I would love to
actually it would be great if all the
critics who you know hoop and it it
would be great to set up a camera in the
room when they were actually watching
the special and see how many of them
were actually laughing but but
afterwards they're like oh no I have to
pretend like I wasn't laughing you know
like it's not it's not right for me to
to agree with this comedy special have
you met low critics Lee this is why you
think if you meet critics they're people
who have absolutely no sense of humor by
and large like there's a guy here that
the Guardian in the UK who he's known
for having absolutely no sense of humor
so like he's known for coming into a
show watching it for an hour and like
people say yeah he smiled twice I think
he's gonna give it a good review so that
I we are in a position where there's a
lot of people who are judging comedy who
don't seem to enjoy it
which is why Chappelle and Jimmy Carr
and and did they get very bad reason a
lot of it seems to be quite political
like coming back to what we were talking
about earlier but talking about sacred
cows what kind of stuff are you
interested in in going out at the moment
what kind of stuff are you working on
with with Internet yeah so we released a
video not too long ago titled
hire minorities to voice your minority
opinions so the that's what we've done
in the show man I'm a foreigner here so
I can do your refugee yeah not quite but
on Russia there you go
the idea being if you're a straight
white this male oftentimes there are you
know certain subjects that you're not
allowed to have an opinion on so this
service will allow you to select a
member of that marginalized group to
express the same exact opinion and it'll
be taken seriously because it has the
authority of coming from a person of
them of that class yeah and and and
that's something that that that subject
in particular is something that that
that I've noticed over the years because
people often begin a sentence with you
know speaking as a as a person of color
or speaking as a woman or speaking as a
man of faith but you know but no one
ever ever starts with it saying you know
speaking as a stupid person
no one ever admits that you know there
are certain identity markers that you'll
lead with but you'll never lead with
you know a state of ignorance like you
know I'm I don't know what I'm talking
about you know before I get going here
that's a very very bill burr technique
the fact is I know I don't know what I'm
talking about but I'm gonna hit you with
this stuff anyway yeah yeah what's it
sound like an example of Socratic irony
hey I'm an idiot guys but and now I'm
gonna hit you with some really wise some
wisdom here yeah no I was gonna talk
about bird just very very briefly
because in this era of political
correctness and you know you know where
you can't say this and you should
apologize you know if you're a straight
white man we've heard enough of your
voices it's ironic isn't it they're
actually probably one of the biggest
comedians of his generation is a guy who
goes on stage and there's entirely
unapologetic for being a straight white
man and I think to myself do you think
that's part of the reason why burr has
you know resonate so hard oh I don't I'm
not sure if it's if it's that
necessarily I think Burgess has a like a
great track record of just doing really
great bits bits that kill in in any room
you know whether it's an urban room if
it's a you know a white room or like
that his stuff just transcends I think I
think it transcend the racial stuff
transcends race and sort of like these
universal ideas one of the coolest
things when I was living in Los Angeles
I got to host a show where Bilborough
was Bill Burt was was a special guest
like an unannounced guest and he did he
did 20 minutes goofing on on Michelle
Obama the first the first lady in a room
in Los Angeles where you know obviously
it's a very you know left-leaning
room and he was able to do this material
and get everybody cracking up and I
think his approach has just always been
so so good - it might be some of that
you know yeah I'm an idiot I'm talking
about and then he's just a very skilled
comedian isn't it but I'm France leftist
I'm disappointed in you for forgetting
to point out one of the greatest
comedians in the history of comedy
hannah Gadsby all right yeah happy have
you seen her special
you know I haven't seen the special but
I saw her TED talk about same thing
about the same thing yeah what would you
guys think of the special I never
actually saw it did you no no I never
saw it I it's one of those things a
moment something becomes extremely hype
and polarizing on both sides I just wait
for it in a couple of years and I
evaluate it on its own merits well it
like it's it's half an hour of decent
jokes followed by a TED talk mm-hmm so
there you go but this we we are in this
sort of era of sort of won't comedy
which you could say Hannah Gadsby's yes
the apex of and she has her critics but
what is undeniable is that she is
resonated
she sells out tours you know you there's
lots of the thousands and thousands of
people who've watched her special number
one what is work comedy and why do you
think it's resonated and why do you
think people enjoy it I'm not sure work
well comedies completely useless well
you know it might be something I think I
think what's great about doing comedy
today is you know from we have the
technology where you know anybody who
wants to wants to do comedy can do it
you know they could start their own
podcast or vlog and all that and it's
it's it's helped to get rid of the
gatekeepers you know because there might
be you know certain gatekeepers where
Hannah Gatsby would never be able to get
to where she is today selling out arenas
and and all that thing and I think I
think no matter what do you think about
Hannah Gatsby or what do you think about
Bill burr or Dave Chappelle it's
wonderful to have all those choices
where it's like oh you know what I can
go my whole life without seeing a you
know a Hannah Gatsby special but all
these people who are into that can go
and and you know and support her and I
and I think you know I think that that's
something that then sometimes we forget
or it's it's pretty good time to be
doing comedy no matter what your comedy
is dude you really think that because
there's a lot of people would argue are
you can't say what you think anymore and
everything
getting shot down and I'm oppressed and
all the rest of it but you say it's the
best possible time to be doing comedy I
think so I think I think they're just
all these different avenues where you
could where you can make stuff happen
and uh all you know sometimes see like
comedians that I know who've you know
been in the game for you know five years
or something like that
complaining about the state that they're
in like oh you know I'm being I'm being
held back or this this theatre won't
have me this Club won't have me and it's
like well well you have an opportunity
there to be a little bit more
entrepreneurial and show people that you
have an audience you know if you could
if you can pack ten people into a room
every week you know to see your show and
then build that up and then build an
online your online brand and all that I
think you need to you need to do that
I've always sort of been of the mind
that I ever since I've been doing comedy
where I can't rely on on you know
gatekeepers or the people you know sort
of in the business or in the industry
it's like I need to just be doing my own
stuff because once you start relying on
other people then you know you're
subject to what they want and what they
don't want I guess that's probably why
you're not seeing some of the stuff that
we're bringing up because if you do what
you do for yourself just like we're
doing trigonometry we're not we don't
answer to anybody
that gives you a level of freedom where
you don't even have to worry about the
stuff but I know certainly in this
country I don't know whether it's the
same in America if you're just a club
comedian which there's obviously lots of
you are at the mercy of you know the
gatekeepers as you say right which is
why it's a great time to be doing comedy
not necessarily to be a stand-up
comedian making your way up through the
the standard industry but it is a great
time to be doing content let's say yeah
right that's a good that's a good way to
put it because I know I know people in
the states who are great stand-up
comedians but they have side jobs they
have side gigs because eat
even when things are going well and
they're you know hitting the road and
doing those road gigs it they're still
not able to to sustain themselves and
they need to work other jobs so yeah
I've never just done stand-up comedy or
even tried to you know go that to go
that route you you're more interested in
what you're doing now with with Internet
yeah yeah production and using that as a
way to you know to book gigs and to and
to do live shows yeah and and all that
well you guys do live shows yeah yeah
yeah we did a tour for city tour back in
November called the funny thing about
hate speech that's that's a great title
yeah and so when you're looking at what
is happening in the US because
everything is so ridiculous now I mean
London take you know even like you know
like George public W Bush when things
were ridiculous and he was coming across
saying ridiculous things it was easier
to parody him but now you see Trump and
not literally yesterday he's just been
impeached I mean how do you satirize
that it must be impossible isn't it it
it seems to be yea very hard especially
I I just don't have the bandwidth to be
able to take everything in you know
there are so many people who seem to
live their lives on Twitter yeah and are
there you know always reacting to
whatever you know to whatever's
happening and I think I think Trump has
done a really good job of we're just
gonna clip that by the way montage of
like children in cages and bombing with
Twitter he's done a really great job you
know sort of misdirecting yeah and in
diverting attention away from you know
really important things
that that are happening but I think also
he's as I guess as a libertarian I I
like when people are more skeptical of
the powers that being skeptical of those
in government and you talk about when
George W Bush was president I I
absolutely loved the daily show at that
time I loved The Colbert Report
I think The Colbert Report was on around
the same time well Kobe actually made
his name if you remember by when he were
invited to speak at the White House
Correspondents which was which I thought
was brilliant
yes great in him and it was fine I loved
it yeah and then what happened was when
when Obama came into office I was like
yes they're going to continue that
they're gonna continue to you know to
speak truth to power if you will and we
really didn't see that and that was
unfortunate I was like oh man here I was
a sort of you know relying on the
comedians to come and take the president
to task and yes I think so I think now
it's sort of the executive branch has
has been you know maybe a little will be
a little less respected you know moving
on and hopefully more people are or are
a little more cognizant of just what
what you know what powers are being
wielded and I think what we you know
what you do it with the Internet is is
actually very valuable because more and
more people have you know they look at
you know for instance a Tonight Show and
they go what you know what this clearly
has an agenda I'm now feeling that I'm
being lectured to by a sort of liberal
left intelligentsia and we get it here
in the UK you know auntie breaks it
which is fine do auntie bracelets some
there are some brilliant ones but if
there is your consistent narrative then
to be brutally honest it gets tedious
and then for somebody like with the
internet to come along and goes look
we're gonna make fun of Trump but you
know we're also gonna make fun of
Hillary you go how refreshing
this is what comedy should be yeah one
of the one of the things that I
absolutely love is when you post
something you post something online on
Facebook or whatever and you have fans
who say yeah normally I like your stuff
but this one was kind of mad and then
they come back and they're like all I
love this video though
I like I like to you know have people
who are able to disagree with you but
still support your work and it's a
challenge to for myself because it's so
easy to just support those who you agree
with and and you know kind of fall you
know fall into that same into that same
trap so I'm hoping that with that we do
get to the point where more people are
able to do that yeah when we have that
word trigonometry as well you get people
who who say oh I watch this you know for
you know a year and a half or whatever
but this video how dare you have you
know this office alone yeah or they'll
start to like we had this video we
didn't into Posey Parker mm-hmm it was
agenda critical X feminist and she was
pretty strong let's say I think that's
the first statement on trans stuff so we
kind of pushed back on her probably more
than we did with others and someone on
the Mumsnet feminist forum went through
and said oh you had she was speaking for
this many minutes and this other person
you interviewed by the same thing they
spoke for that and it's because you're
two men and it's like come on but but
eventually you kind of what I what we
always talk about is like you have an
audience that is your core audience and
over time that will shape up to be what
it is and people who who thought it was
like a right wing echo chamber or or at
this kind of echo chamber that kind of
echo chamber they all get filtered out
and what happened that was taken down
right yeah it was taken down as hate
speech and then eventually reinstated
probably because we had good there was
quite a backlash against there we were
starting to get traction in in the news
and stuff like that
do you have you ever had any problems
with Facebook or anything yeah yeah you
really yeah we've had problems yeah so
we had one it was
forget how long ago but I ran a poll
right yeah and I and I asked who was
responsible for Hurricane Florence right
and let's see 25 percent of the people
said Donald Trump and the other 75
percent said the gays
thank you thank you for laughing and
there was only two
there was only two options right right
and obviously anybody reading this knew
that it was a joke it was a play on you
know who controls you know Jews yeah and
I think it was like over 10,000 people
voted in this in this poll and shared it
around and it was taken down because it
went against community standards and it
got me thinking you know like man you
know here is here it is like the censors
on Facebook are doing away with what's
clearly satire yeah man who knows what
else they're doing away with and we've
had an issue recently with we have an
old video that I shot like right after I
think was a Ben 2017 or something like
that right after the inauguration the
presidential inauguration and it's
making fun of aunt Eva it's like here
are six rioting tips for aunt Eva and
that was flagged recently for promoting
violence and I and I wonder how much of
it is sort of the attempt to get an
algorithm that can catch every you know
every single like problematic thing and
then you know you're gonna have a lot of
stuff that just sort of gets gets caught
up in it that shouldn't be but yeah
we've had issues with Adam in those
cases where they manually reviewed and
then reinstated or I'm not I'm not sure
I think this one we I think this last
one we called for a manual review and
I'm not sure what what's happened yet
but until then it's you know we're now
we're thinking oh no like we have to
beware be wary of certain keywords you
know violence or anything that could
that could you know get picked up as
potential hate speech and and it's tough
when you're creating content to try to
stay ahead of the curve and knowing you
know what it is that we can and cannot
publish without worrying about it being
taken down but this is the problem with
censorship is that if you if even if
it's an algorithm which I actually in
our case it wasn't in when with the posi
Parker video was taken down based on a
manual review of it and then we had a
manual appeal again was that was that
changed the back
but even if you even if it algorithms it
forces you as the person who's putting
stuff out there to censor yourself yeah
and then you won't tackle the issues
like you say the sacred count you'd
rather stay away from it and and do a
video about something that's going to be
less controversial yeah and when you're
talking about D monetization you know
there are you know places like like
Prager University that'll pretty you
that that talks about their videos but
you know a lot of people on the Left who
produce videos their stuff has been D
monetized as well and it's you know you
wonder is it keywords is it manual
review is there a you know a type of
vendetta I don't know and do you think
that they've become more draconian as
the years have gone by social media I
think I think so yeah yeah and and
they're you know they're dealing with a
with a lot you know companies like like
Facebook they're dealing with you know
having to do congressional hearings so
they have to go before you know Congress
and and answer questions then they're
dealing with people who you know are
using the system and and hate it
and then they're also dealing with you
know some weird stuff that they've done
before regarding you know sharing
personal information and security
breaches and then also the work that
they do in other countries as well I
don't think it who knows I mean made in
the United States it's probably not as
bad as it is in you know Saudi Arabia
Saudi Arabia has you know allows people
to have Facebook I don't know yeah I was
gonna ask you so in terms of this you
said you had some problems on YouTube as
well was it just demonization if he had
to start taking down I think yeah I
think we've had stuff demonetized and
there was for a little while
there was another video it was there's
another Antipa video it was called
should aunty fast stop and it was taken
down for a little while because it again
it was saying that it was like sort of
promoting promoting violence and if you
watch this video should aunt Eva stop
it's not promoting violence but now it
was reinstated but now it's age
restricted so you have to be 18 or older
so yeah it's do you think we're rapidly
coming to a point where people are
misunderstanding irony they just don't
get it anymore mm-hmm and you know you
can you can make a joke that is ironic
you can put a video out that is comedic
and people will go oh we're just simply
would take that literally therefore get
rid of it well yeah I mean look at you
have Snopes fact-checking a satirical
site like the babylon beach yeah and
that's almost its own its own case of
all this can't be this can't be real
yeah I don't know what it I don't know
what it is that why that's the case that
people just aren't getting irony I mean
well we have the stereotype in in
Britain about Americans the Americans
don't understand sarcasm and irony so it
could just be that it's run by Americans
well you guys are really good at it hey
I gotta say you know you talk to enough
breath and you're like it's because
we're deeply emotionally repressed is
thing and we can't actually say what we
enjoy so the only thing that we can do
is just take the piss out of it yet be
calm carry on yeah anyway be passing
very on because that's just fine yeah
so where's where do you think the future
is kind of the culture it's an
interesting time we're recording this
just after the election here in the UK
where the the bright of center party has
absolutely crushed there and it seems
like a lot of the reasons that that
happened was the cultural stuff to some
degree so the landscape seems to be
shifting what do you think if this were
to happen if let's say Donald Trump is
reelected in 2020 which seems certainly
credible it was possible what do you
think that kind of cultural landscape is
going to look like
I'm afraid that things might get might
get worse before they get better
yeah I'd it's almost it it's almost it's
almost like everybody needs to hit rock
bottom before we're able to rebuild
again well like an alcoholic yeah yeah
yeah but for 350 million
alcoholics need to need to hit rock
bottom I was talking to someone who
works in in Silicon Valley about tech
and in particular
Kancil culture and I was telling them
how you know I really would like to
explore that idea of canceled culture in
tech and how how technology and social
media has basically facilitated
facilitated that and with the hopes of
you know getting bringing our culture
back to one of forgiveness one where you
know hey you posted something stupid a
few years ago we're gonna let it slide
and lettin up make you lose your job and
you can go about go about your day and
he said I think it's a great idea it's
not gonna happen okay really it's not
gonna happen he's like he's like he's
like no it's gonna get worse and worse
and worse more people are gonna be mob
you know joining you know mobs and
trying to get rid of people and that
sort of thing oh my god that's he's like
an insider that's great but trigonometry
yeah yeah when the bombs start falling
you know we'll be well you guys will be
safe I don't know where I'll be so he's
gonna get worse you think we need to
have Rob why do you why do you say that
why do you think you think the
polarization will continue is that your
sense yeah I'm afraid that that it will
that it will happen and I don't well
there are you know a lot of people I
guess in the states they call the
exhausted majority who are very tired of
of the squabbling I wonder how many of
them will be exhausted and go you know
to one extreme you know go to one
extreme or the other I'm sorry this is
such a pessimistic this pessimistic view
it might because there's raining and in
London for the past as well I have lived
in the city with shitty weather not [ __ ]
great country shitty weather for 25
years now and you never get used to it
yeah to be honest with you I'm inclined
to agree with you I think the problem is
with Twitter
it just emboldened shitty behavior in
narcissism and as a result of that I can
just you know
and I've seen comedians go through it
they take these extreme positions and
then get on a positive feedback loop
where people are retweeting them and
then they're getting more likes and then
that encourages that position and it's
[ __ ] brilliant
I'm enjoying it yeah I wonder to it just
how many how many times I've you know
tweeted something and then you know look
back on it a couple of weeks and like
and think if if everybody just knows me
from that yeah you know it's like oh
that that's a shame you know there's a
lot more there's a lot more to me than
this shitty take nuances very hard isn't
it like I I've thought about this often
if you just look at my Twitter feed you
would make assumptions about me that
aren't true okay yeah okay well listen
man it's it's an interesting time and I
really enjoy what you do so please keep
it up and we'll keep watching it the
last question we always ask is what is
the one thing that we're not talking
about as a society that we ought to be
talking about oh well I think you know
sort of with the holidays coming up I I
think it's so important to really
embrace the real-life relationships that
we have and to let the people who are
important to you know how important they
are and I don't think it happens enough
and I I'm in a really great position you
know being able to do comedy and I also
get to have interactions with fans of
mine and a little while back I had a fan
of mine reach out on Facebook and he you
know said said to me something that I
consider pretty heavy he said you know
I'm thinking about trying comedy because
I think it would give my life some
meaning to create yeah yeah and and you
know you hear that it's like whoa you
know what's going on I asked him what
you know what you know what's going on
in his life and he said well for the
past year or so he's been taking care of
his his grandmother who has dementia
right and I said to him I said man you
know you know what you've what you're
doing for your grandmother
such an incredible thing I mean you know
what can be you know more life-affirming
and then taking care of those who need
who need the most and and he he said wow
you know thank you for for reminding me
of that I didn't think about that and I
was thinking like here here you have a
you know a young man who's you know
doing good in the world
who's been blinded to the good that he's
doing and he only needed was one person
to remind him hey man what you're doing
is is amazing and yeah you can do comedy
too and that could be a part of your
life but what you're doing is very
meaningful and has it can have a big
impact on people and it's you know I
wish more people would uh would do that
and embrace it because it can go a
really long way well you said that with
the holidays coming up this video will
probably go out after me always a
holiday if you haven't done that you're
a bad person but try and do it I love it
that you deliver that message when
everyone's come back from Christmas in
his entirely [ __ ] sick comedy you
might not have enjoyed Christmas dinner
but they are really important yeah so be
nice sorry this is the cynical sense of
humor yeah thanks very much for coming
on man if people want to watch your
stuff and follow you whether they do all
that yeah we the internet TV on YouTube
in Facebook and Twitter and then I am
Lou on the subway on Twitter perfect
fantastic and as always we'll see you in
a week from now with another grab so
take care see you next week guys thanks
for watching guys as always subscribed
to the YouTube channel click the bell
button next to subscribe button so you
get notified when a video comes out and
follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod and also leave us a nice
review on iTunes and spread the word